as Biden's poll numbers continue to
slump well buckle up for what will be as
I was just saying one of the most
negative campaigns in American history
without anything positive for Joe Biden
to run on if you can name something
please text us email us at the Hannity
Show we'd love to hear from you the
Biden campaign as I said democracy in
Peril while by the way at simultaneously
trying to kick Republicans off ballots
little ironic isn't it they'll obsess
about Donald Trump Donald Trump they'll
never want to talk about Joe's Records
everything about January 6th except the
facts you know like the police chief
Capital police chief's son uh the
remarks peacefully patriotically uh
March to the capital so your voices will
be heard those facts that narrative
anything that doesn't fit their
narrative they in fact won't tell you
about they will demagogue abortion and
as I said employed the left wing classic
identity politics that Playbook like
never ever before right on Q anti-trump
pton County DA Fanny Willis now blaming
the serious misconduct allegations
against her on racism anyway here to
respond to all of this Texas Senator Ted
Cruz by the way another person that
actually you beat Donald Trump in
2016 uh in Iowa at the Iowa caucuses and
uh and you ran a very tough campaign
against him um your thoughts about last
night well Sean it's great to be with
you listen last night was decisive it
was it was a dominating victory for
Donald Trump I I got to say there's no
place like the Iowa caucuses I know it
intimately the men and women of Iowa
they take their responsibility
incredibly seriously they scrutinize the
candidates it's an amazing process and
I'm a big believer in letting democracy
play out well last night it played out
and I I got to say Trump's victory was
across the board he won 51% of the vote
he won 98 of the counties
congratulations to president Trump on
that dominating Victory and and at this
point I I believe this race is over so
so I am proud to endorse Donald Trump
for president of the United States I
look forward to supporting him
enthusiastically because I think it's
time for the Republican party to unite
for us to come together we've got to
beat Joe Biden we've got to beat this
disastrous cultural Marxist agenda in
the White House we've got to retake the
United States Senate we've got to hold
the house we got to come together and wi
and with the results last night the
people have spoken it's time to move
onward to victory in November so do you
basically think when you look at the map
it's going to be New Hampshire Nevada
South Carolina super Tuesday you know
the map as well as anybody when you look
at that map what do you
see look I I I don't see any path to
victory for anyone other than Donald
Trump New Hampshire may be closely
contested we'll see what happens I think
after New Hampshire it will go to South
Carolina believe in South Carolina
you're going to see Trump win a
dominating victory in South Carolina a
and after that you've got super Tuesday
I don't see a path for any candidate
after that and and and I'm a big
believer we need to let the process play
out it did and the results last night
51% 98 counties that that that's
compelling and and at this point I think
the contrast needs to be on substance
and policy and Records you mentioned a
minute ago the classic test of any
presidential race are you better off
today than you were four years ago and I
got to say for just about every person
in America the answer is hell no and
unless you happen to be a big Tech
billionaire or a Mexican drug lord The
those guys they ought to vote for Joe
Biden because they have done fantastic
over the last four years but if but
Senator I've got to take issue with you
you're obviously not listening to the
media mob and you're not listening to
Joe and the vice president Harris and
you're not listening to Circle back Jens
Saki and Karen jeanpierre and Alejandro
mayorcas because they have been telling
us the borders closed and the bord
secure those 10 million people that we
know now have entered this country
illegally many from countries that don't
like us our top geopolitical foes many
with deep ties to terrorists uh are
showing up at that border but you know
obviously it's closed and it's secure
because that's what they keep saying are
they lying to us they are absolutely
lying and I got to say I really enjoyed
that Montage you started your show with
of of Jake Tapper and Rachel mattow and
all these leftist crying it reminded me
of I I will confess anytime I'm a little
bit little bit down I like to play
Rachel matow on Election Day in 2016 and
the absolute shock and pain and Agony
shodon Freud is not a pretty Instinct
but but they are look they hated Trump
in 2016 they hate him even more now they
are broken they are liars there's a
reason I agree with what Mike hucke said
there's a reason they cut off Trump's
speech because if they actually believed
it was as horrible as they said they
would want to play it but they don't
Jake Tapper just wants to say
anti-immigrant listen I'm the son of an
immigrant from Cuba but there's a right
way to come that is legally and I'll
tell you my home state of Texas there is
no state in the country that is bearing
the brunt of this Invasion more than the
state of Texas and Joe Biden and the
Democrats they don't give a damn they
don't care about the dead bodies that
are piling up they don't care about the
children who are brutalized the women
who are sexually assaulted the more than
100,000 people have died of drug
overdoses and I think the American
people are fed up with this chaos of the
border and they recognize that much of
the corporate media is just lying to
them yeah well said um I noticed Chuck
Schumer has targeted you number one um
you will likely be facing at the time bo
boo as I called him a rock was
considered a real candidate and got a
ton of money over hundred million if I'm
not mistaken I don't know why but every
time you run for reelection you are
maybe the second most hated Man Behind
Donald Trump in politics they really
they're gunning for you big time uh
politically speaking well listen I wear
that as a badge of honor but you're
right if if you are a left-wing Democrat
after Donald Trump there's nobody in the
country you want to beat more than me
and Chuck Schumer's made clear I am his
number one Target in the country the
Democrats are going to spend $100
million this year trying to beat me and
trying to flip Texas blue now that ain't
going to happen I got to say last time I
went on your Show the incredible viewers
of Hannity I encourage folks go to
tedcruz.org tedcruz.org tedcruz.org
thousands of people went to tedcruz.org
they made contributions online it is
powerful because we're going to defend
Texas we're going to defend the country
and we are going to win the White House
and and send Joe Biden to Green Acres
Retirement home the one thing I can say
is you are a solid conservative you have
been your whole life I wish more
Republican Senators thought like you and
fought like you uh anyway we appreciate
you breaking news about endorsing
president Trump tonight uh we always
like breaking news hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else